[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE COLEMAN: Hi, I'm Mike
Coleman, a developer advocate
here at Google Cloud.
And in this video, I
want to talk to you
about how you manage your
applications after you've
migrated them using
Migrate for Anthos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Getting your application
containerized
is just the first step.
You'll also need to
consider how you manage
that application going forward.
How do you handle
base operating system
updates, application patching,
and other Day Two tasks?
The rest of this video aims to
answer some of those questions.
As a quick side
note, I'm not going
to spend a lot of time talking
about how container images are
constructed.
If you're not familiar with
that topic, pause the video,
go check out the documentation
on the Docker site
and come back and rejoin me.
Also, if you're not familiar
with Migrate for Anthos,
check out our
earlier videos where
we provide an overview
of the service
as well as how to perform
an actual migration.
You can find a link to those
in the description below.
With that being said,
let's take a look
at how Migrate for Anthos
creates the container image
from a migrated application.
Migrate for Anthos automatically
examines a source VM
and extracts the
workloads running there
into their own container images.
When looking at the ongoing
management of those containers,
it's important to understand
how their images are actually
built.
The container that
you run in production
is a combination of two
intermediate images.
The first one is the Migrate
for Anthos runtime layer
and the other is what we refer
to as the non-runnable system
layer.
The non-runnable system layer
contains the extracted portion
of your migrated
workloads and will
serve as the base for
all future updates.
As the name implies, this layer
by itself doesn't do anything.
It's only by combining it
with the Migrate for Anthos
runtime layer that you get
a container image that you
can deploy into production.
So let's look at the
Dockerfile so you can
see how this works in practice.
Now, the Dockerfile
uses a multi-stage
build to combine the
two artifacts together.
This first FROM statement
tells Docker to use the Migrate
for Anthos 1.6.0 runtime image
from the Google Container
Registry, and to refer
to it going forward
as, quote-unquote,
"migrate-for-anthos-runtime."
The next FROM tells
the Docker file
to use the image
that was generated
when you ran your migration.
It's also stored up in the
Google Container Registry
under your project.
Notice that Docker will refer
to this image as, quote unquote,
"source-content."
As an aside, while
I am specifically
using Google Container
Registry in this example,
depending on where
you're migrating from,
we can also use AWS'
Elastic Container
Registry or a local registry.
This section is where you
would run any updates,
and we're going to
cover that in more
detail in the next section.
So for now, we'll
just skip over it.
This line tells Docker to
copy the file system starting
at the root from the
migrate-for-anthos-runtime
into the container image.
Now, remember that the container
image we're copying into
is the source-content image.
So basically, this command
copies the runtime container
image into the
source-content image.
And the last line
tells the container
to run the v2k.go
script and start
your migrated application.
Now, as I've said,
this Dockerfile
is what's used to create
the migrated application
configuration that you initially
deploy after running Migrate
for Anthos.
But what do you do
if, down the road,
you need to update the
image for some reason?
For example, you need to
install an updated dependency
or patch your application
or upgrade the underlying
Migrate for Anthos runtime.
Going back to our
Dockerfile-- now,
updating the
migrate-for-anthos-runtime is
actually pretty simple.
You just go back to
that first FROM line
and you update the version.
If you need to update any
part of your application,
including system or
language libraries
or the application
code itself, you
would do that after the
second FROM statement.
So, for instance, if
I'm a node developer,
I might copy in a
new package.json
and run "npm install"
to update some
of the packages my
application is using.
Or I could copy in
a new app.js file
to update my actual
application code.
The underlying file
system in the container
is the same as what
you had in your VM,
so you would just
update the files
in their original locations.
Now, from here,
you could manually
run docker build to
create an updated image,
push that to GCR,
and then roll out
the new version of
your application.
But manually building
the new container images
could become tedious if you are
regularly processing updates.
A better approach is to
use a tool like Cloud Build
to automate the process with
a modern CI/CD pipeline.
By leveraging a tool
like Cloud Build,
you can define triggers
such that whenever
a change is pushed to your
source code repository,
a new container
image is created.
And once that new
image is created,
you can perform manual
or automated tests.
And then finally, using either
manual or automated processes,
you can push that code
out into production.
Let's take a look at
how we would implement
a pipeline in practice.
I'm going to construct
a simple pipeline that
will connect to my
GitHub repo such
that when I push a
new change to GitHub,
a new container image
will be pushed up to GCR.
From there I'll update
my Kubernetes YAML
and roll that updated
app into production.
OK, so let's go ahead here.
We're going to start
in Cloud Build,
and I want to show you the
trigger that I built earlier.
Remember, a trigger is
something that can kick off
via different processes.
So we have a trigger
here that when
I push to a branch
in my GitHub repo
here to do a Cloud Build where
I've installed the GitHub
app for Cloud Build.
When I hit the master
branch with an update,
it's going to go ahead
and run a Dockerfile,
and it's going to do that in
the root of the repository,
looking for a file
called Dockerfile,
and it's going to build
us a new image that
is tagged with the short SHA
of the build process, right?
So that'll be our unique tag.
And then if we look
down here below,
what we can see is the
actual Dockerfile build-- er,
the docker build command where
we're going to build that
and we're going to
point to that Dockerfile
that I just mentioned.
So that's what's going
to happen whenever
I push a change to my repo.
Now, this is the Dockerfile.
We talked about this
earlier in the video.
You can see here is the runtime.
Here is the
non-runnable base that
is created as part of
the migration process.
And then what I have added
to it, if we come down here,
is I'm basically saying, copy
the contents of this repo
into /usr/src/todo in
the container, right,
in the container image.
And that's where it
was located in the VM.
That's where it was--
the code was located
in the container, as well then.
They're the same.
So now what I want to
do is I want to come up
and I want to actually go ahead
and make a change to my source
code.
So I'm going to come up here
into this showTasks file
here at the top, and
I'm going to click here.
And I'm going to go in-- and
I'm not running these on VMs,
so it's not a host.
It's actually a pod.
So let me change this
to pod, and then I
will save this file out.
And then I will move down
here into the terminal
and I'll do a git add *
to add the change file.
I'll commit that to the
repo with a commit message
of "update host string."
And then I'll go
ahead and do a push.
Now, this push will
kick off that trigger
that we just talked about.
So if I come into history, you
can see it's already building.
So we'll come in here
and I'll show you here
in a second when this comes up.
You can actually see
there's that commit message
I used, "update host string."
This is going to take a bit,
so let me pause the video
and I'll rejoin
you when it's done.
OK, so we've finished up here.
And if we come down,
we can see there's
where we copied the source code
into the image, as I mentioned.
And here's that
short SHA and we're
going to use that to do the
update to our application.
So let's go to the
image repository here--
Container Registry.
Look at the images.
And that's where the
non-runnable base gets stored
by the migration process.
And there's the todo directory.
That is where we actually get
our deployable applications.
So there's the one
we just created.
And now we're going
to deploy that
by opening up a Cloud Shell
and editing the Kubernetes YAML
file.
So let's open this up
and we're going to move
into the directory where
the artifacts are stored,
and we're going to edit
the deployment_spec.yaml
and we're just going
to scroll down here,
and we're going to change
that tag on the image name
to the one we just created.
We're going to save that out.
And then we're going to
go into the terminal,
and we're going
to go ahead and--
well, before we do that,
let me point this out.
So it says "served by host."
That's what we're
going to change.
So now let me go here and I
want to go ahead and clear
the screen.
And then we'll do a kubectl
apply -f deployment_spec.yaml,
and that's going to update the
statefulset with the new image.
Let's do a get pods with a watch
so we can watch that happen.
And while that's happening,
I want to just talk
about a couple of things.
One, this is not exactly
what you would do, right?
There would be a step
between building the image
and deploying it, and that would
involve some sort of testing.
We talked about that.
And the other thing is you
could automate this step
if you wanted to, right?
In the video, we
don't really have time
to go through that process, but
you could fully automate this
so you automate your testing.
You automate the
sign-offs and the release,
and then you automate
the push to production.
Here we're just basically
automating the building
of the container image.
We're assuming a manual test
step and a manual deployment
step.
All right, so we're
almost done here.
The containers should
be up and running
in just a couple of seconds.
And looks like it's
just about done.
So let's go and check
on that application
and see if our
change got reflected.
So we'll come up here,
click on todo list app,
and you can see down here,
actually there it is.
It's now served by a
pod instead of a host.
So the application
has been updated.
So in this video,
we talked about how
you can use a Cloud Build build
trigger connected to a GitHub
repo to automate the
creation or the updating
of your migrated applications.
That about wraps it
up for this video.
I hope you found it useful.
If you want more information
on Migrate for Anthos,
we have some additional
videos posted here on YouTube,
so check those out
and then head on over
to
cloud.google.com/migrate/anthos
to learn more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]